so normally you guys do a reading at
these things and we're gonna instead
just start this with some conversation
the the book literally came out
yesterday in North America is that right
yeah so I assume not too many of you
have have read ahead so we're not going
to do too much in the space of spoilers
but there's there's already a little bit
out there and and we'll we'll talk a
little bit about some of the the
mechanisms within the book at least but
I think first a lot of people would love
to know and I know that there's you guys
met prior to the Mongolia but work
together on the Mongolia and then and
then are here so maybe say a little bit
about the Mongolia and a little bit
about your working process that got you
to work on a book together I'll take
this one okay the mongoliad was a
collaboratively written serialized bit
of alternative historical fiction that
was written by seven folks Neel five
other males in Seattle and me I was
added I was added when they realized
they needed a little estrogen added to
the equation and we wrote it over the
course of approximately a year year and
a half and it was originally intended to
be just come out online and then it
ended up being published as a trilogy by
one of Amazon's imprints 47 and one of
the first one of the first things that
they printed and then it was followed by
a couple of other books that were
written by smaller collections of people
but we what what was involved in writing
it was once a week the six people in
Seattle would get together and hit each
other with sticks for a while and then
sit
have coffee and donuts and Skype me in
and we would talk about story and figure
out who was writing what chapters this
month and it was an interesting bonding
experience by satellite for me and by
the end of it we all still liked each
other nice and the origin story of this
book didn't really come directly out of
that but that was how your first writing
experience how what how did this start
yeah previously we Nicky and I had known
each other for a few years because we
share an agent and we share an editor so
the but yeah I I came up with the idea
for this this story this world for some
reason on Thanksgiving Day I think it
was 2013 I just woke up in a Comfort Inn
on the outskirts of Clinton Iowa where
was a Thanksgiving trip and I just
basically wrote it down and the and then
it when when it looked like I was going
to turn into a novel project I thought
of Nicki right away because clearly it's
a time travel narrative and it was going
to involve sending contemporary
characters back in time to various
historical time periods and I thought it
would be a match for for what Nicki does
and we had had the experience of working
together you know on on the other book
and so I knew that it was just going to
work and it did and I know that some of
these things come from kind of esoteric
technology research they that you do and
and this one and the time-travel part is
based in some string of that as it were
the is when you say this just came to
you is there was there something that
you were working on or researching that
that brought you around to it I don't
know it was just one of those weird
things that kind of popped into my head
there was there's sort of a connection
back to some of the stuff I was thinking
about with with Anitha
having to do with that there's a whole
it one of the things I became aware of
when I was working on an attempt it's
that metaphysics is is a real thing it's
it's not just like a quaint old thing
that people used to do but they are
living by the physicians who do that for
a living and and and one of the things
that they talk about is possible worlds
or alternate worlds and it ends up
getting tied in with the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics on
the physics side of things and so that
was just an interesting it was just
interesting to me that that people could
actually sit around and think about that
it's like a serious topic of of you know
of academic study so so that would that
kind of stuck with me and and the part
of what we're doing in this book is is
playing around with that and trying to
eliminate some of the the well-known
logical paradoxes and problems that you
get into when you're trying to write
time-travel literature so the rules of
the of the game in this book are that
first of all the most recent time you
can go back to is July 1851 so we get
rid of the whole why don't you go back
in time and kill Hitler thing you know
don't even have to talk about that
and then the and then the other thing is
that there's multiple strands so it's
not just one pass that leads to our
future but there are many different
slightly different versions of the past
that that get to vote on what their
common future is going to look like and
so if you if you wanted to you know if
you wanted to go back and kill Hitler
it's great-great-great-grandfather you
could do that but you'd have to do it 20
times in different versions of the past
in order for it to stick right so it
makes it it creates a cost to those
efforts that become increasingly
difficult and also when you go back that
that far and you have you change one
variable the repercussions spread out in
a bigger way so yeah you can't go back
in time 20 years or 30 years and invest
in Microsoft stock or it's not something
like that you could go back to the 1820s
and buy whale oil futures or something
but tracing that through to an economic
benefit today you know is a less certain
proposition and nici that I think what's
interesting about this this book and
that's coming out also in such in a way
in proximity to arrival coming out that
the one of the the lead heroine is a
linguist and the you know that in in
both cases in a way that government
helicopters land and say you're the most
important person in the world right now
and I realized that they're not really
you know they're they don't share much
other than that but I think it's it's
curious that we have this and you know
one of our projects or is around
linguistics the Rosetta project where
we've been trying to catalogue all these
things and so heroes that are linguists
are important to us but I'm wondering
where where the hero linguist part of
this came from and your guyses process
Neil Neil that was part of Neil's
initial image of it and she has to be
the hero linguist in order for the story
to work I was delighted to be given that
as a care
- whose voice could evolve she anything
that I would say about like why that
might be happening why there's the rise
of like the kick-ass female linguist
would be specious and you know
superficial so I won't go there away
with it I could
I mean clearly like we're in a world
where the more we communicate the more
distant leaf you know the usual tropes
did I answer your question
no I did I just find it interesting that
yeah that we have that now it's great to
get a female linguist are historical
linguists are they are the heroes I'm
not action movies I'm not a linguist but
I was a nerdy enough kid involving
language that when I was a kid like I
would read nerdy like books about where
language comes from and I don't think I
made as much use of it as I would have
liked to but there's little places where
the fact that I know a little bit about
little bits of language kind of work
their way in and given the opportunity
I'd certainly do more of that well you
should mention the reader of the
audiobook oh yes so um small world
Department the my college roommate and
best friend was a Harvard linguistics
major and the character in the book is a
Harvard linguistics major and after
being a linguistics major she went on to
become an actress and a voice-over
artist and she is voicing the Harvard
linguistics major that's awesome so yeah
we we arranged this event a little bit
late and I got my advance copy digitally
and I was like maybe this is a shorter
book and so I'm halfway through now and
I realized as it you know and when you
get your book on your Kindle you never
really kind of know how long it is but
after four days of reading and 40% the
way through I don't know it's one of
those books and and so it's exciting
that I've been and I've been going
through it but you tend to write long
books and and now you even in
collaboration you're writing long books
in an increasing culture where we have
shorter form things and I'm I wonder how
that's you know working for you
the D do you always want to write long
books or how does that work it's it's
what I do it's not it's not a matter of
wanting to necessarily but it's I think
you know I my observation is that first
of all there's plenty of long books that
appear to do quite well and end up on
bestseller lists and and get adapted
into TV shows and movies so so clearly
there's a market for for great big long
books and I think the people who who
read them enjoy the sort of indulgence
of Total Immersion prolonged immersion
in a big complicated world and I think
that explains why long-form television
has become you know overwhelmingly
popular and successful medium in the
last I don't know 10 years or so is
precisely because people kind of revel
in the opportunity to get lost in a
great big fictional universe and then
the more that we become like the the
land of tweet Twitter the more that
there is this sort of broke that a didi
is sort of celebrated and found useful
the more we need the long-form stuff to
bounce counterbalance that I think ya
know I mean we also see you know
podcasts obviously that can be hours
long that are becoming more popular not
less popular so there seems to be some
divergent set of humans are wired to
want that to get through the long winter
nights and so on and that and that
that's in a way just something inside of
us is craving that enough that
culturally were returning we're moving
in that direction while we're also going
in the other direction to balance it out
also within the book it's an epistolary
novel so there's many different voices
that are that are telling the story and
some of the some of the storytelling
happens in very very short byte so I
don't think there's there's no Twitter
in it but there's there's correspond
appreciation if there's there's like
interoffice members laughs there's the
equivalent of slack so so basically of
Twitter like
but that's interspersed with much longer
narrative yeah it's not 750 pages but
there are some long there's some very
long letters from the past yeah and yeah
you don't mention the mechanism of those
letters at least not yet
are they are they coming forth as as
things from the past or are we reading
them or or would that be giving away too
much because I haven't gotten that yeah
I think the overall conceit of the book
is that this is an archive of stuff that
was leaked from the from the servers you
know of this fictitious organization and
someone's gone through and curated it
and been pulled out enough samples from
that that big archive to tell a coherent
story and so in some cases you're
reading transcripts of ancient documents
that have been recovered and you know
scanned and in other cases it's just
direct downloads of you know a slack
thread or something and I I felt a an
interesting link to actually one of your
shortest books a first there was the
command line there's a there's a a funny
bit about operating systems and
interface in in this one does it have a
backstory at all or really they're very
well they're using a operating system
called shiny hat which is the the most
secure geeky operating system in the
world and it only works on the command
line because mice and all that or are
insecure and so it's kind of created by
the most paranoid OS geeks on earth too
so that they can be safe from government
surveillance and so this is the
government becomes aware of it they just
buy them out and adopt the operating
system because it's so cool and that's
the operating system that is now used
internally by this top-secret government
organization
but yeah I don't know it's just a throw
a joke because because one of the one of
the things that comes up when you're
writing this kind of book is that you
know you want to throw in some technical
details like you know what kind of
computers do they use what kind of
operating system do they use and
anything that I put in is going to be
wrong you know if I just quote does
mention a specific real operating system
or what-have-you so it's more fun to
just make something up
nice we're gonna open up the questions
in just a second but yeah I think the
the other what it turns out I guess was
not a what was also a fictitious bit was
a brewery that's that's used but the in
in our research for creating this place
one of the things we learned is that
some of the oldest companies that are in
continuous operation tend to be
breweries bars hotels and and that that
comes up here and also goes back to the
name of it was a was a linguistic thing
that you found as well here she here
she's here she which I named after a
doll tearsheet who's a character who's a
prostitute in the Henry plays
Shakespeare's Henry plays Henry the
fourth but it is also just a he wasn't
being terribly original when he used it
if you know what prostitutes do all you
have to do is think about it and
tearsheet it makes a lot of sense some
of the action takes place in in
Elizabethan London and has centered on
the old tearsheet
brewery which is adjacent to a theatre
so thank you for that context all right
do we have mics for questions or we yep
all right we have one up front
if you have a question and maybe for
both of you question on research for
historical novels now and I guess you've
been at it long enough to be done it
back pre-web and you sort of have to
wander around and whales and stuff like
that but so much richness on the web I
was researching an historical period or
fiction changed over time you know I I
haven't really changed my methods at all
because the more information there is on
the web the more unreliable information
there is on the web so I usually will
between real libraries and what I can
find on Google sort of get a very very
superficial level of like hmm what is
there to look at but you either want to
go on site or try to go to closer to
preliminary sources you know primary
sources to get the material I I just
but yeah the more there is the less you
can trust of what there is well you
mentioned last night that when you were
working on fool's tale which is set in
medieval Wales you basically read
everything yes existed on that time in
place because there was a finite amount
there still is a finite amount but I bet
if you went on the web it would seem
like there was three or four times as
much and did you do some traveling for
this one No and so we cheated in a sense
and like for instance we wanted we knew
that we needed a medieval there's a that
one of the story lines is medieval and
we wanted it to be a medieval setting
where there was a lot of fighting and my
novel crossed is about the Fourth
Crusade so I suggested that we make the
thing that the fighting is about the
Fourth Crusade so then I didn't have to
travel because I traveled ten years ago
for that one and I still have my notes
right and then and you have some
background in medieval sword fighting as
well yeah so some of that finds its way
in there's a whole they they end up
having to create a department in the
organization called dubs the department
of violence's and ethnology because the
it's not just enough to
no particular historical sword fighting
style but violence or the willingness to
use violence and use a particular weapon
in particular circumstances is very much
it's a very much a social construct
right I mean it's there are certain
rules about what's acceptable what's not
acceptable and if you're going back in
time you have its you can't just be a
berserker swinging a sword around but
you've got to know what for example
there was a rule in some medieval
society as if you drew your sword more
than three fingers with out of its
scabbard that that was essentially a
threat of violence and so so at that
point you're justified you you can first
of all you can be arrested but if if
you're Square right you could be could
be arrested by the authorities or killed
by the other person and so there was you
know a certain amount of you know trying
to goad the other person just yeah right
so that's the kind of thing that you
would have to know so in the in the book
this fictitious government organization
ends up having a whole staff of people
that just sits around and studies that
kind of thing
nice you mentioned in writing the
mongoliad that you alternated chapters
or head divided up my chapters can you
talk more about how you co-authored this
particular work I mean did you divide it
up that way you develop the character it
wasn't nearly as structured we just
didn't the question oh you can hear it
cuz it's on the mic um it we just wrote
what needed to be written when it needed
to be written we have we realized Nicky
and I have realized that we need to make
up a whole bunch of fake stories about
all the drama and tension and excitement
of trying to work together because
in reality you know she would just go
write a bunch of stuff and then I would
she'd mail it to me and I would work on
it and it just worked no stories to tell
at all but so so she would write she
would typically go ahead and write a
chunk of it send it off to me and then
make my pass through it while she was
working on the next bit and we used a
spreadsheet to keep track of chronology
and that's all there was to it it's a
very confuse of time travel for this
particular story the chronology gets
very very complicated and that but the
the chronology was about as officially
organized as we ever got we had to make
we had to make [ __ ] up like the
something called you debt which is unity
of doer experienced time so if if you're
the doer the diachronic operative you'd
the agent and you get sent back on a
mission that takes three days do you
come when you come back to the present
do you show up three days after you left
or could you come back the moment after
you left right and and then how much
have you aged if you were to do that
right then you get into the problems
like you could have somebody you know go
off on a 70-year mission and come back a
microsecond later and they would have
aged by 70 years in a microsecond which
that seems wrong and so we had them too
so we've got out of somebody writing a
whole little mini dissertation embedded
in the book explaining why you can't do
that and it's called it's called the
unity of doer experienced time or are
you dead and what one thing we haven't
mentioned here which does appear early
in the book just like the basic kind of
premise of time-travel is the is magic
and this the whole the the year at which
that you can go back and the way time
travel works is intertwined with magic
do you want to talk a little bit about
where magic and
in science cross over here the simple
answer is that it you a witch has to
perform magic for time-travel to happen
but because Neil Stevenson is involved
with this book there is of course a
scientific explanation for how magic
happens and it makes perfect sense when
you read the book so there aren't wait I
can be slightly less than that there is
there is a reason that magic used to
exist and no longer exists and it has to
do with the effect that technology has
on magic which if we were reading the
section that we were that we read at
bookstores that's the section that we
where we talked about that so come to
the book store tomorrow night right well
yeah there'll be versions of those
readings abound we have a the mic in the
back and brain front yeah thanks my
question is about is also about your
writing process how do you go from a
world or a technology and idea to
explore to a character-driven story with
a plot or does that all come together
blank stares we don't actually know how
it's done magic yeah I mean I think
there's always a compulsion or a
requirement to have a good yarn with
some interesting characters doing
interesting things and it all boils down
to that and sometimes you start with
with that with a you know a idea for a
story or a story event and build on that
other times maybe there's an idea for a
world like in this case I think it
started out with an idea for a world and
then the where it came from or how it
got started is the story that we we
invented to support that and
to the degree that I have an actual
answer to that my backgrounds in theater
I grew up acting and became a director
and so I think in terms of character
most of the time anyway so that's the
most I can come up with characters more
easily than I can come up with plot or
structure so it was awesome that Neil
had this idea for this story because all
I had to worry about was filling in the
characters interesting over here right
here hi I was wondering about the idea
of temporal cultural dislocation like
when you think about time travel have
you you must have thought about how far
back within one sort of native culture
you could go in time before you become
non-functional have you had any
interesting thoughts on that when you're
saying non-functional do you mean that
the culture is not functional or that
you well you need to to the degree that
it's possible they're part of the huge
government bureaucracy involves a bunch
of has m''s historical work or
historical operations subject matter
authorities there we go who prep you to
the degree that it is at all possible so
it's a weird it's a weird combination of
like SEAL Team six training camp with a
liberal arts college and a Renaissance
Faire
where do I sign up for that and also
almost astronauts too right there's the
I think in just along those lines
getting into the part of what's your gut
flora content and your virus
contamination going back and forth in
time becomes a really interesting
question just like kind of the
decontamination of the astronauts it and
new world travelers so there's there's a
physical side to it as well as the
social side so that's one of the reasons
that important character is is a
linguist is because the the the most
obvious and superficial answer to the
question you asked is well you'd have to
speak the language right and then of
course that's just the scraping the
surface beyond that you'd have to know
so the first thing that that the
linguist character does is go back to
colonial Boston in the 1640 so the
language there's something of a language
change right which isn't a terribly
difficult thing to deal with but there's
all of this other stuff that she has to
know yeah from how she dresses to what
the social norms are body language how
you even hold yourself if you're wearing
a corset if a woman is wearing a corset
she's gonna carry herself differently
and have different sets of muscles that
are stronger or weaker because she's
being supported in a different way that
sort of thing but because it's she lives
in Boston in the 21st century that's a
fairly easy destination time and place
DTaP is the term that's a fairly easy
DTaP to prepare for and then it just
sort of gets further and further afield
from there yeah her danger is often
around just being a woman walking around
the Sun escorted yes yeah which was
clearly different carrying so Joseph yes
I'm sort of building on your question or
your answer about the sort of technical
thinking through the technology of time
travel and so on there's a lots and lots
of novels in science fiction about time
travel do you try to anyway either
rectify it with respect to other choices
people have made or to comment on other
choices people have made or in any way
just now we just say it's magic and once
you essentially they they figure out a
way to get magic working again by making
a kind of Faraday cage that within which
a witch can do magic and then it turns
out that most of what they can do is not
that useful it's like where did I leave
my keys you know I have a headache I
have a headache you know so it's a lot
of the things that the magicians might
have done in the past it seemed really
valuable at the time are things that we
can do a lot better today so it's a
little bit underwhelming at the
beginning and then they real then oh by
the way I can send people back in time
so it's just sort of thrown out there
without any attempt whatsoever to
explain any you know it's just magic
it's just something they can do I've got
a quick question but after I asked it
catch my eye if you've got a question
we've got I'll pass the mic to you next
and yeah your your next day so can you
say something about you you Neil you
read a lot about scientific exactly
researched scientific things and then
also you make up your own rules on some
things can you say what you whether it's
more fun to like research and figure out
oh how can I do that is that possible is
it more challenging is it what what are
what are the differences between kind of
making up your own rules and then having
to follow them versus the natural
science stuff I think the key to it is
having some rules and kind of sticking
with them
it's not whether or not those rules are
terribly scientific isn't as important
all right so if you watch Star Trek it's
just full of complete hogwash from a
science point of view but but nerds like
it anyway because it's consistent
hogwash right so so as long as you don't
give readers the sense that you're so
breaking your own rules for your own
convenience as a writer then I think
you've gotten satisfied readers and so
in this case you know as I as we've been
saying the effort was to create a set of
rules around magic and time-travel that
that we would then try to stick with in
a consistent way and when we encountered
places where we were violating our own
internal consistency we would just use
that as a springboard in trying to solve
it usually it allowed us to come up with
new storylines that went in new
directions so like the biome thing that
you brought up you know we kind of
realized halfway through that wait a
second there would be contamination both
ways right so anybody in this room going
back to some previous time could trigger
a plague wherever they landed because
we've got germs that people in the DTaP
aren't don't have immune systems against
but likewise we might get sick from
their germs and so I so in order to
address that you know we have to we had
to come up with the notion of the whole
sort of bio containment protocol and the
whole separate research arm in this
organization that just kind of works on
that problem and that gave us some fun
scenes in the book that wouldn't have
been there otherwise so that's story as
yeah as storytellers you guys talked
about kind of the this story being a bit
piecemeal and and kind of broken up into
for sections or bite-sized bits peace
meals some are bite-size summer yeah
so I mean I'm curious if like if there
was a process around how you organize
that so there was kind of a consistency
or a threat that pulled you through each
each story element maybe how that worked
for me it felt pretty intuitive I think
it's kind of an interesting sort of an
instrumental thing that the epistolary
format makes it really easy to fast
forward right so if you're trying to
tell things in a linear way you're you
you see it's hard to jump in to engage
the hyperdrive and and summarize a lot
of stuff quickly
so whereas if you can just terminate a
document and then jump into an email
threat or something that happens a year
later or what have you then you can kind
of fast-forward through a bunch of
intervening narrative that that wouldn't
have been that engaging to read you know
if you it was all written in a direct
narrative style so I think that was I
think a feel for pacing and when to jump
ahead was was a big part of that yeah
but also at a certain point it sort of
became almost like a game to games not
quite the right word but it became fun
to see what options we had for that kind
of storytelling so there's a there's a
piece of poetry that when we started
writing it I would not have guessed
would be in the book it's and there it
is and it works nice do you have any
more questions
in science fiction and alternate
histories for example I think I'm
remembering this correctly in
Steinbeck's Arthur aim the mic in your
face yeah he goes back and he he knows
when the clips is gonna happen any gains
power from that prediction or you have
some technology which you leverage in
Star Trek does this to you have
something on everybody from what I'm
hearing from you it's almost sort of
like deliberately the opposite where you
learn a lot of things about culture and
stuff in order to succeed it is
deliberately the opposite because
there's another rule I forgot to mention
which is that if you make huge changes
like go kill Napoleon it creates a
complete disaster
and so it's all butterfly effect Massa
Nations right and so like somebody might
get sent back to a pub in Belgium in
1512 and say you know there's a big
redheaded guy sitting at the corner
table your job is to spill his beer and
then get out that's all you know or or
open the stable door and and run away
that that's your whole mission right
you're going to train for this and do it
20 times in different versions of the
past so so it's kind of a deliberate
flipping of this of heroic Connecticut
Yankee in King Arthur's Court version of
things where you
you you can't do that you're not allowed
to make those big changes and instead
you're this kind of furtive creature who
sneaks in and you know like unfolds the
napkin or does something like that and
then gets out and the reason I asked is
that you're both really interested in
history which is not directly science
fiction you were more science fiction
before so there's sort of a
historiography in here that's built in
and thinking they're small interventions
have big changes I think that's true in
real history right so if you just say
you know Portuguese got spice or like
they're actually pretty small but they
have these giant economic consequences
what are you trying to say with that
mechanism I don't want you to out the
book but like by using that what are you
trying to say about history broadly by
making the napkin yeah we're not trying
to say anything we're just telling a
story yeah well I think a good crossover
point here is where science fiction and
history meet and obviously time machines
are an awesome one mechanism as it were
and this in just last week we had James
click talking in effect about the
history of time machines and had the
literary kind of origins of them did you
dive into some of these versions of
other time machines or I did once we
finished it just out of curiosity like I
really deliberately kind of tried to
stay pristine in in our understanding of
what we were doing then afterwards just
out of curiosity I read other
time-travel stories just to see how
other folks had done it and I think we
have more rules than most people I
didn't see that Jim Glick had that book
out so I should check that out now yeah
his talk was on our podcast shortly I
think you would enjoy the book I think
another co-authorship question both of
you professional writers you're managing
your writers voice you've really
developed that skill over time what's
involved in sort of blending your
writers voice so that I
reader can't tell when when you're
writing or when you're writing but it's
all one story but I please correct me if
you disagree with what I'm about to say
um I think that because I started doing
the like I was I was the first boots on
the ground that the the main narrator's
voices I sort of started and Neal
started voices that came later in the
book and then I think we just mimicked
when we needed to if he needed to change
something that Mel was saying
Mel's voice was strong enough that he
could do that and there's character that
shows up later named Mortimer and when
Mortimer when I needed to change
something of Mortimer's I tried very
hard to just make it sound like Mortimer
which Mortimer had a clear enough voice
that I could do that so for your next
project you can write in Neil Stevenson
novels okay we're gonna do our last few
questions that we'll move on to the
inscription part of the afternoon hi
Sean it sounds like it was a lot of fun
to play with the social norms of past
cultures and I'm sure the reader kind of
reflects on today as a result of looking
through those past lenses at what point
in the process did you say oh that's a
fun and interesting mechanism was that
built in from the beginning or did you
just kind of arrive you mean using the
premise of time-travel to comment on the
quirks of different cultures yes I think
you have to think about how quirky all
culture is if you're gonna put yourself
outside of it to write about it even
your own culture and beyond that I would
say it just emerged directly from the
specific story that we were telling and
the the places that we were sending our
characters so it was probably the
biggest single extended chunk is in
Elizabethan
London which which Nikki knows a lot
about because she's a shakespeare geek
and so so there's a lot of behavioral
detail and cultural detail in there that
I would not have known about and I want
to make sure that I give you the chance
either the chance or the always the
worst question for an author is what's
coming up next but do it separately or
together or their projects that that
that you do have coming up in the future
that you do want to talk about
separately where I mean we had a great
time working together but it's not our
natural state is to withdraw to our
caves alright question hi I was
wondering did you have a linguistics
consultant for the book and how did you
choose them if so careful this is a
linguist asking the question oui oui
the right one we got a really pointed
questioning on this front from a
University of Washington linguist on our
first night of the tour who badly wanted
us to know that linguists aren't just
people who translate things and and so
the and kind I guess the funny part if
you want to think about it this way is
that when Mel is initially recruited
it's some dude from the government who
who thinks that way she's like I need a
bunch of stuff translated that's what
you do here's some money please do it
and then a lot of what the story is
about is her growing outside of that and
the other character realizing how much
more valuable the linguist is in all the
other parts so yes I think it it does a
good justice to this because Laurens my
my friend from college she was voicing
now because she does have a degree in
linguistics when she read it and did not
come back to me and say yeah you know
you're really screwed
up that just her not saying that made me
feel like okay dodged a bullet there
thanks a lot
nice do you have any questions from the
live stream or should we move to our
next phase I haven't I don't know
there's one follow-up
Neil you were here two years ago for
four 70s and you mentioned at the very
end that you had already started working
on your next project so is is this the
project just to connect the dots is this
the project you had already written a
couple hundred pages of or is it the one
that's that's forthcoming probably it
was probably this one yeah and can you
say anything about since we going back
to 17 years for a second
say something about the reception of
that obviously some made the Bill Gates
and and Obama lists and anything to
share about what that feedback has been
like or are there reflections on it now
it happened it was really cool that it
happened didn't you know I didn't have
any the the Obama thing was a surprise
there it's not like the it's not like I
heard from the White House you know or
anything like that just showed up on the
list and in in the Bill Gates case we
ended up doing a video together which
was a pretty crazy morning driving
around Seattle in a tesla pretending to
have a unscripted conversation about
which it was unscripted that definitely
say that but so there is if you look
there's a an amazing 360 video that his
staff put together for his blog which
which records that but you know it was
it was obviously cool and good that the
book got that kind of reception and it's
the kind of thing that I try to not
think about and just keep my head down
and keep keep writing new stuff
you know thank you well I want to thank
you guys for adding us to your insane
schedule coming through here and and do
encourage the people here to to do to
either go to the reading or now that you
have the book you can read the part of
that reading we're gonna set the room up
sorry oh did you have a question from
the oh we do it we did have we did have
maybe one last question if I was curious
you mentioned sort of realizing the
biome thing halfway through out of all
the issues that time-travel brought up
which was the one that was the kind of
like or like if you had one this were
like oh crap moment that required like
sort of stopping for a week and like
thinking through I don't think we ever
had to stop for a week but what so what
was the I got that but what was the
actual what was your most difficult yeah
time travel problem Oh like issues that
time travel brings up which was the one
that was like the hardest that required
the most sort of thought and I think
once we had the basic rule set in place
I mean that was that was important the
you debt thing was was important just
say you know sending a few other rules
like that yeah a lot of it was just sort
of adapting as we as we went along
talking about it thank you guys as you
know Neil you probably already have one
of these but to add to your collection
of challenge coins all of our speakers
and Nicole this one is yours thank you
guys for coming by and collection yeah
so have some patience while we reset the
room and one more let's have a big round
of applause for presenter after
[Applause]
[Music]